time now for one of our favorite
traditions here at cbs this morning
we are revealing the grammy music
educator of the year it's part of our
road to the grammy series
where we count down to music's biggest
night the recording academy's
63rd annual grammy awards this year's
music
educator award goes to the drum roll
please
jeffrey murdock an associate professor
of music education at the university of
arkansas
murdoch's an educator a conductor and
leader of
two of the university's choruses jamie
wax visited him in fayetteville arkansas
and found a man dedicated to paying
forward all that he has received
the university of arkansas's
inspirational chorale
[Music]
knows the value of a mentor he's
honestly like a dad to a lot of people
he's like a big brother to a lot of
people i mean he's anything that
you need him to be in that moment nice
work man this is good
because their mentor knows that value
too
so i started out playing piano when i
was five years old
and there was a family friend who paid
for my piano lessons
having someone to to kind of get that
seed planted
for me was really meaningful to to who i
am now
do you ever think about what your life
would be like if
this family friend had not done that for
you at that age
i do think about it quite a bit it would
be a very bleak existence i think
for me jeffrey murdock grew up in a
rough neighborhood in biloxi mississippi
i grew up in a part of town where it was
not uncommon to see people getting shot
and killed right in front of my house
and so i appreciate the the village that
was around me that helped me overcome
those odds
that village included music teachers who
fed his passion
and guided him
[Music]
including the first black teachers he
ever had this
is such an example of what we hear about
a lot and speak about
uh that representation is so incredibly
crucial to creating a possibility in a
child's mind indeed
indeed absolutely and i think if it had
not been for those musical experiences
with
african american teachers i'm not sure
that i would have
had the same trajectory i mean i always
say that i wanted to be a meteorologist
[Music]
weather's loss is music's gain and
murdoch makes paying it forward a
priority
to have a black professional mentor
in the position that he's in to really
take me under his wing it is just
i'm blessed what makes dr murdock
incredible is that
yes he's an incredible musician he's an
incredible director but he goes the
extra step in
educating us in just life things
educating us how to be good citizens
good
peers good friends good mentors and that
never stops
for him that's a 24 7 thing teach the
students that are in front of you
not the students that you wish you had
it's why he not only leads the choirs
but also
teaches the next generation of music
educators
as many music teachers as we can keep
out there and as many folks as we can
get to continue planting those seeds and
giving students
those meaningful experiences i think
we're making the world a better place
one kid at a time
citizen basis drop out go and it's why
even though he's a college professor
he still makes sure to engage with
students of all ages
from first grade through high school
i've been so passionate about
young kids and just and students of all
ages
and lifelong learners that i can't get
myself out
of the high school classroom out of the
elementary classrooms it's just
it's my happy place
what do you hope your legacy is i hope
that if people remember me for one thing
only
that they remember that jeff murdock
loved students
that jeff murdock loved students
unconditionally
and gave them his all for cbs this
morning
jamie wax fayetteville arkansas
i say it every time one great teacher
can change your life and yeah it's
someone like jeffrey murdoch i love that
he said you teach the students you have
not the ones that you have yes that's
good advice for a lot of things actually
but i like when he said jeff murdock
loved students unconditionally and gave
it his all message received
yeah message received it's good that he
found his happy place